ce journal bruno mégret nationale
l'église catholique certaines régions
génocide des juifs pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale
gildan rattrapé par ses affaires dans le
pétrolier amoco et corrigé par la mairie
leonardo dicaprio gérard depardieu
jérémy l'élection des conseils régionaux
a donné hier une majorité à la gauche
mais elle peut encore réserver bien des
surprises tout au long de cette semaine
en effet et à l'occasion des élections à
la présidence vendredi prochain en effet
si les états majors ont donné des
consignes très strictes pour ne pas
accepter à droite les voix du front
national dans différentes régions
elle est prise de position sont beaucoup
moins claires ainsi n'est pas exclu que
le verdict des français soit
contrebalancée par des combinaisons
politiques pour l'heure il faut rappeler
les résultats tels qu'ils sont désormais
officialisés qui montre un rééquilibrage
des régions à gauche une victoire pour
la majorité actuelle mais en aucun cas
une déroute pour l'opposition
sébastien guibert vendredi prochain la
gauche se représenter en rouge pourrait
présider au moins onze régions contre 2
seulement avant le scrutin la gauche
c'est-à-dire le pc le ps et les verts
obtient le plus grand nombre de sièges
notamment en aquitaine languedoc
roussillon provence alpes côte d'azur et
surtout en ile-de-france la droite en
bleu a donc reculé mais elle ne s'est
pas effondrée elle devrait conserver
sept régions dont l'alsace la lorraine
l'épée loi ou encore la bretagne
l'auvergne reste trois régions au
résultat final incertain les écarts sont
si serrés en poitou-charentes
rhône-alpes et franche-comté köhler
or dépendra des transactions pour
l'élection des présidents vendredi au
niveau national en pourcentage l'extrême
gauche progresse à plus de 4% l'année
ans pc ps verts divers gauche devance
d'un point environ l'union rpr udf
divers droite 37% contre 36 à l'extrême
droite le fn se maintient à 15%
les autres listes dont les chasseurs
atteignent 7 % quant aux
abstentionnistes
ils étaient fort nombreux hier 42% des
électeurs inscrits ne sont pas allés
voter
un record pour une élection régionale
mais pour mieux comprendre si l'on prend
les problèmes posés région par région en
provence alpes côte d'azur détenu
jusqu'à hier par la droite la majorité
relative et donc à gauche désormais le
front national réalise globalement un
bon score et parvient en deuxième
position dans au moins trois
départements françois léotard qui était
le chef de file de la droite refuse
toute idée de compromis avec le front
national
mais quelle darmon en prime des mines
sa compagne avait débuté par un discours
optimiste à toulon elle s'est terminée
hier soir dans le silence sur la
canebière de marseille
qui ne l'a jamais adopté françois
léotard accuse sa défaite
juste quelques mots avant de se retirer
de la reine pour une nuit seulement 4
même blessé le président de l'udf fait
qu'il ne peut pas se taire c'est plus
qu'une défaite c'est une épreuve
ce n'est ni la déroute pour la droite
républicaine et le triomphe pour la
gauche socialiste et communiste mais
c'est une épreuve pour le pays tout
entier
retour sur la soirée électorale côté
gauche plurielle en mairie d'ars le sort
politique de la région provence alpes
côte d'azur bascule des vents michel
vauzelle l'alluré mais monsieur pépy
l'ancien garde des sceaux sincérité - de
l'usure président de l'abej
ce week-end ce grand 12h20 publicains et
bien à redonner aujourd'hui la première
place à la gauche
je vais plus à toulon jean-marie le
chevallier celui lui aussi au rituel de
la séquence télé le front national
progresse encore dans cette élection est
venue cette fois des bougies des élus de
droite film la couleur des conseillers
régionaux
ut1 faire père ne rompt pas la sottise
ce qu'omet avec est socialo communisme
ils seront rejoints les deux camps de la
droite
disons plurielle avec le front national
mais la poussée du fn en paca ne gêne
pas les calculs de la gauche plurielle
michel vauzelle président on s'était
encore il ya quelques jours à souligner
de campagne aujourd'hui cette affiche
sur laquelle lumière à nous unir et
réalités politiques région symbole s'il
en est l'île de france a perdu dans les
urnes sa majorité de droite le
socialiste jean paul huchon devrait
prendre la présidence et de larmes à la
dure qui était le chef depuis l'erp et
edf a clairement confirmé ce matin qu'il
ne se présenterait pas à la présidence
pour l'instant on ne signale pas de
dissidents de droite qui pourrait malgré
tout se présenter à ce poste reportage
carole common gens n'existent pas d'être
régional d'île de france
on change les ciels les derrière le
rituel des lendemains de soirées
électorales
la première région de france vite un
bouleversement politique
dans la bousculade de la victoire comme
pendant toute la campagne de la gauche
et dominique strauss kahn qui
monopolisent l'attention c'est lui qui
fait la première déclaration relayée
ensuite par le futur patron de la région
balladur
notre guerrier
des choix qui n'ont rien le sourire est
encore de rigueur mais la tension est
palpable depuis le début de la soirée
s'est passée le majorquin sur
l'historique du rpr est tombé mais dans
sa courte déclaration
edouard balladur préfére évoqué les
conséquences nationales d'industrie
temps de cette situation toute
l'opposition portent la responsabilité
collectivement
quelles qu'aient été ses frais nous
devons maintenant en privé d'éléphant à
gauche on a déjà sorti les roses et pour
beaucoup il page vient d'être tournée
c'est très belle victoire et les
sentiments politiques
je pense particulièrement à chaque fois
si balladur qui représenterait l'achat
de voix françois hollande que le premier
secrétaire du ps vient savourer la
victoire
ile de france a voté à gauche et la
gauche est ravi du symbole parmi les
trois régions qui reste vraiment ce soit
indécise poitou charentes franche-comté
rhône-alpes et c'est cette dernière qui
est la plus tangente d'ailleurs elle
dépend en fait pour la majorité actuelle
dirigée par charles millon du vote de
deux nuls un chasseur et un régionaliste
savoyard qui font monter les enchères
midi guyot avait trois quarts et alain
roux passionné de chasse et amoureux de
l'ardèche a de quoi être comblée grâce à
douze mille trois cent quarante quatre
voies le voici élu au conseil régional
l'avenir de charles millon ou deux jours
jacques queyranne dépend en partie de
lui
et déjà on cherche elle séduit j'ai eu
droit comme une politique autonome
couteau je pense que généreux je vais
rencontrer rapidement les grands chefs
de partis politiques qui s'en est
proposé qui sont concurrentes pour la
pause argentin patrice abeille est un
nouvel élu également très sollicités
président de la ligue savoisienne il
mise pour une sa voiture et indépendant
il évoquera pour le président qui aura
su écouter les voix de ses 4000
adhérents
personne n'a voulu prendre ça en compte
bien maintenant je représente ceux qui
pensent que oui la savoie un avenir
européen en tant qu'etat souvent les
petits 2 millions de 40 20 minutes vous
écoutez ça
à ce jour ni patrick ça baigne alain
roure ne savent où ira leur bulletin
vendredi prochain quant à charles millon
ils dans un appel ces deux élus mais
aussi à tous les autres quels qu'ils
soient qui sera tenté par son programme
je pense avoir le soutien de tous celles
et tous ceux qui approuvent notre projet
je pense avoir le soutien de toutes
celles et tous ceux qui à pour notre
projet je pense que sur le front
national je n'ai aucun geste a montré
compte tenu de ce que j'ai fait depuis
dix ans je dis carrément d'observateurs
aux critiqueurs aux analystes que dans
ce domaine là ils ont qu'à voir le
placide quelqu'un pour juger son avenir
jean-jack queyranne pas question
d'accepter la moindre voix du fonctionne
en plaques qui depuis hier
l'exemple même encore de l'hésitation de
certains leaders de l'opposition le
languedoc-roussillon à montpellier le
président sortant jacques blanc unef
pourrait être élue avec les voix du
front national même si la gauche est
arrivée en tête pour l'instant jaguar
n'entend pas passer d'accord avec le
front national qui pourrait le faire
élire mais il ne récuse aucune voix en
accord avec son programme
reportage françoise david denis
permanent montpellier la ville où les
hommes politiques
invisible donc muets et apprennent ici
lui détient la majorité absolue la
gauche plurielle a certes la majorité
relative mais le président sortant
jacques blanc n'a pour autant pas
renoncer
il veut pas froisser demande avec les
traits ellul front national que je vous
dise à revenir
et dès hier soir jacques blanc laissait
la porte ouverte je ne signerai pas
d'accord
italien il faudrait qu'il voudra et je
les respecte
parce que s'il s'agit de diaboliser un
succès écoutez ça suffit je me bien
balisé par jeu presque toute la journée
l abri des vitres fumées coups de
téléphone et monnaie nationale
on accroît signé van tu elle mais ils
ont la sueur si soutien il doit y avoir
il ne sera pas gratuit
l'exigence c'est un engagement formel et
simon de baisse des impôts est aussi un
engagement de faire rentrer des
compétences de la région
la sécurité dans les transports
organisés mais comme elle sait si c'est
court c'est vrai six mètres s'est
précipité au niveau des postes je veux
dire pas de poste si nous en a fourni
refusera pas où les repères pas plus
qu'à l'idée qu'on ne souhaite s'exprimer
ce soir on fait les comptes
le parti de jacques chirac a osé lui
autant que son allié et finalement le
rpr qui pourrait bien détenir vendredi
les clés de l'élection du président de
région
la fisam l'an passé un accord avec le
front national les conseillers régionaux
et repères on peut continuer de se
désolidariser du président sortant faute
de quoi ils encouraient la sanction
suprême l'exclusion pure et simple du
mouvement chaque os nommé ray bonsoir on
l'a compris au travers des différents
reportages le front national met dans
l'embarras un certain nombre de
présidents de longtemps en difficulté et
l'on sent que vous avez des propositions
alors faire différent de ce qui s'est
passé de celle qui était faite la
semaine dernière
on va notre position elle est
extrêmement simple il n'est pas question
en effet d'alliance nationale avec les
états majeurs du rpr et l'udf
mais si on plan local régional en
l'occurrence un certain nombre d'élus du
rpr udf de bonne volonté
et vol qu'un barrage à la gauche socialo
communiste nous sommes d'accord pour
dialoguer avec eux et ce dialogue et il
peut se traduire par un soutien en
quelque sorte un soutien sans
participation du front national né à
condition bien sûr que les grilles kuti
fort questions prennent en compte une
partie de notre programme afin que les
intérêts de nos électeurs soient prises
en compte lors quand vous dites une
partie ça veut dire que vous relance
auriez un certain nombre de vos idées
fortes par exemple la préférence
nationale des choses qui sont
inadmissibles a priori d'après ce qu'on
sait du côté du rpr et l'udf
alors il ya dans les préoccupations qui
sont les nôtres la sécurité la baisse
des impôts ça a été dit dans le sujet
tout à l'heure mais c'est vrai que nous
sommes des gens réalistes celle des gens
de pondérer et dans la mesure ne sommes
qu'en situation d'un mineur qui n'est
pas question pour nous d'imposer la
totalité de programme donc une partie
seulement et ce notamment celles qui ils
ont est la plus susceptible d'un
consensus
alors sur la préférence nationale bien
sûr que ce n'est pas moi qui ai suggéré
qu'elles soient mises en oeuvre à
vitrolles qui veut dire qu'il faut
renoncer à la préférence nationale
d'ailleurs pourquoi ne l'accepterai t-il
pas en 84 à paris si la rue de londres s
est pas mais nous acceptons que tu as
fait de ne pas mettre ce point là en
avant dans le cas de ces soutien sans
participation qui pourrait cette mise en
oeuvre pour la santé si vous amène comme
ça et a évolué à adoucir je suis si je
puis dire votre position par rapport à
la droite modérée il s'agit pas de
l'adoucir il s'agit simplement de
prendre en compte la dimension très
importante est en train de prendre le
front national s'impose maintenant comme
en quelque sorte deuxième boule
structure de la vie politique française
face à la gauche
et maintenant qu'il s'agit et
éventuellement un soutien sans
participation
sommes déjà en route et un soutien sans
participation c'est pendant toute la
législature de ce conseil régional vous
êtes d'accord pour ne pas revenir sur un
certain nombre d'autres positions vous
mettre d'accord vous étiez d'accord sur
une sorte de contrat exécutif sa peau à
tête sous cette forme là ce qui nous
permettrait de juger et de vérifier
l'exécutif en question appliquent bien
le programme qui est le nôtre sur lequel
il se serait engagé est ce que vous
pensez qu'un certain nombre de
présidents peuvent être intéressés les
kane écoutez moi je le pense je ne veux
pas mouraient les faits révéler quoi que
ce soit c'est à le faire mais il a
actuellement quatre ou cinq présidents
de régions potentielles qui
manifestement sont intéressés et qu'il
vous pouvez atteindre des régions où
c'est une force d'appoint mais en
revanche par exemple d'une région comme
provence-alpes-côte d'azur là est ce que
vous proposez aussi bas en provence
alpes côte d'azur la situation est très
différente car actuellement on sait plus
très bien où on en est avec monsieur
aulas et kalia efforts fournis dans ses
plus aux normes est de toute façon il ya
d'un côté le candidat de la gauche de
l'autre candidat du front national le
problème il est un peu inverse
est-ce que l'été est conseiller régional
rpr udf ont voté pour la gauche ou ont
voté pour le front national ça c'est ce
jean marie le pen est d'accord avec
votre proposition
pas tout à fait puisqu'il a annoncé lui
même tout à l'heure les six mesures que
nous souhaitons voir prise en compte par
les exécutifs nous pourrions soutenir
l'action que vous avez entendu ce même
de bruno mégret quelle serait votre
réaction en cas d'accord accepté par un
certain nombre
de droite en difficulté je crois que ne
faut pas que la droite où les leaders de
la droite
localement en particulier ajoute le
déshonneur à la grèce est elle est
faible a dit constater hier
je crois que ce serait très grave
la droite française d'accepter ce baiser
mortel
pour nous les choses sont claires depuis
l'origine
elles sont d'une clarté biblique nous
reconnaissons que la présidence revient
au parti qui a obtenu la majorité
relative et nous mettons en accord ses
engagements et nos actes
exemple en auvergne donc on connaît son
nom par exemple comme la région comme la
picardie où le président socialiste
peut-être à lui grâce aux voix
communistes là on entend des
responsables du rpr ou de lunel dire eh
bien là c'est la can avoir écouté une
alliance clair net qui a été négocié
discuté ratifié dans le pays en juin
dernier une nouvelle fois approuvée hier
par un pas grand nombre le français
c'est à lyon c'est le gouvernement
chinois rien à voir avec une alliance
entre une droite dite républicaine est
un parti d'extrême droite
je crois que nous à nous assistons nous
à sesto amplement de la part de certains
caciques locaux adham notable à des
marchands la halle jusqu'à présent en
coulisses la table à présent presque à
ciel ouvert qui se chante âge du front
national qui font rire les fonctions qui
joue la danse du ventre devant les
leaders du front national qui sont prêts
à ramper pour sauver quelques malheureux
siège de président c'est manqué
t j'ai envie de vie n'était et je crois
que ce qui compte en démocratie c'est de
respecter l'engagement pris devant les
électeurs
autrement c'est un viol ou un vol des
voix des électeurs c'est un véritable
détournement
il n'est pas normal que dimanche les
français aient voulu que la gauche
gouverne dans plusieurs régions dans de
nombreuses régions et que vendredi à la
suite de combines le vote des français
soit remis en cause
j'ajoute que de nombreux électeurs de
droite seraient eux-mêmes révoltés par
de telles conduites maison ils vous font
oublier que dans ce pays il ya 85 % des
gens les électeurs qui ne veulent pas du
fond la chaîne a donc je dis aux leaders
de la droite
refuser ce baiser mortel refusé cette
alliance mortels et j'attends
nous attendons que les ni d'adam droite
nationale je dresse comme un seul homme
pour désavouer ses tentatives de
présidence magouilles disent non à ces
arrangements
il aurait dit oui au respect des
électeurs un mojito les pompes
monsieur lang entre curieuse conception
de la démocratie lorsque ils essayent de
fausser le résultat des élections est le
jeu qui résulte de la composition des
assemblées il essaye de mettre en place
avec le rpr udf un autre une autre règle
du jeu on se met d'accord entre nous on
tient pas compte des électeurs du front
national
récit d'une façon d'exclure 15% du
peuple français de la démocratie et de
surcroît que ceux qui exercent un
chantage actuellement c'est évidemment
pas le front national qui n'est
demandeur de rien il n'a rien à protéger
rien à défendre c'est le ps et le pc qui
exerça spes de chantage
ahurissant sur les leaders du rpr udf le
plus ahurissant d'ailleurs c'est que ces
leaders s'y soumettre docilement et
serviles noir
dans le quotidien la loyauté à l'égard
des électeurs
la plupart des responsables de la droite
classique on dit tout au long des
derniers jours qu'il n'accepterait pas
ce genre d'alliance avec le front
national
à commencer par monsieur balladur et
quelques autres hauts responsables pour
que le minimum que l'on trouve aux
électeurs c'est le respect des
engagements dont le comprendrait pas que
le vote des français de d'hier est un
vote pour le changement se traduisant
lundi prochain par le retour au pouvoir
de leaders locaux dont le pays ne veut
plus payer et je digère japon est gelé
jeudi est majoritaire et jeudi que
droite républicaine où seraient soulier
est salie par ce type d'alliance et
c'est d'ailleurs ce que cherche le front
national a souillé shalit depuis
longtemps tiens déjà commerciaux hic
c'est bien vous merci messieurs merci
messieurs d'avoir été présent ce soir
sur notre plateau parlons maintenant des
problèmes qui se posent à gauche
également dans le nord pas de calais
n'est pas la seule région sur laquelle
on négocie à gauche les écologistes
n'ont pas globalement réaliser lé score
escomptés notamment dans le nord pas de
calais ou suite à des différends la des
différends internes
la présidente du conseil régional marie
christine blandin s'était présenté
contre la liste de gauche nos michel
delbarre elle arrive loin derrière et
elle aura bien du mal à conserver son
fauteuil reportage évite un bear même
une fois ci les résultantes été
soigneusement épluché fidèles sont
autour de la table de cette première
réunion ce matin michel delebarre s'est
entretenu avec lionel jospin au
téléphone il n'y aurait pas d'autres
scénarios à négocier après six ans de
présidence écologistes la région nord
pas de calais doit revenir au pays
marie christine blandin elle ne l'entend
pas ainsi il est réserve destination
paris le siège national ne voulait
garder la présidence de cette région et
on a prouvé
bref le bras de fer semble une nouvelle
fois engagé en prenez deux prétendants
même fauteuil et la confusion s'installe
un peu plus dans le feuilleton du nord
pas de calais avec en prime l'arrivée
d'un nouveau second rôle
lutte ouvrière et c'est cet élu
indispensable à l'émergence d'une
majorité de gauche
résultat le plus étonnant la droite
elle-même pourtant défaite dans les
urnes se met à rêver tout y compris le
fait que la gauche n'arrive pas à garder
n'est c'est la deuxième réunion de la
journée chez michel de bain il sait que
marie christine blandin n'a pas renoncé
à briguer la présidence les électeurs
ont choisi
nous avons plus de 30% dans le nombre
d'électeurs qui ont choisi une
proposition et il a un peu plus de 8% de
l'epr qui ont choisi une proposition de
madame blom et pourtant il est 17 heures
à paris au siège des verts la présidente
du nord pas de calais persiste et signe
elle s'en remet aux arbitrages nationaux
de la majorité prg et les verts comptent
bien jouer tout leur rôle et occuper
toute la place qui leur revient
jusqu'où montrons les enchères pour les
écologistes manifestement le contrôle de
la région nord pas de calais où se
négocie au prix fort non répondent les
n'est pas la seule région sur laquelle
on négocie à gauche des socialistes sont
réunis cet après midi pour examiner au
cas par cas
plusieurs régions notamment avec leurs
partenaires communistes guilaine chenu
jean-louis buissière
la maison qui reçoit aujourd'hui c'est
le parti socialiste toutes portes
ouvertes pour commencer les négociations
la gauche est en mesure de gagner une
dizaine de régions le problème c'est le
partage
je ne peux pas annoncer des présidences
de région avant que nous n'ayons eu la
confirmation à travers les résultats et
surtout la discussion avec papa c'est le
respect que nous devons aux électeurs et
à nos partenaires aussi rien n'est
décidé
au moment où je vous parle mais tout est
déjà en train de se préparer
ici c'est un peu la salle des machines
on analyse on calcule on prévoit ce qui
est négociable
au vu des résultats les quatre partis de
la majorité plurielle ne pourront pas
chacun avoir une présidence les premiers
à faire le déplacement sont les verts
une rencontre discrète dans un café
parisien
il revendique toujours la région nord
pas de calais malgré le faible score de
marie christine blandin deux heures de
discussions et c'est le ps qui payent
l'addition d'un sursis savoir si le but
région webdo une région nice alors
également les vice-présidences notamment
en ile de france
la barre est très haut les verts veulent
sixième des vice-présidences le
communiste pierre belote à lui via tout
seul son parti revendique une présidence
vous êtes entendus ce mardi nous conte
moment nous nous sommes entendus sur
rien nous avons fait un tour d'horizon
nous allons examiner les différentes
possibilités qui vont se présenter
la base des négociations à gauche c'est
une dizaine de régions gagnables s'il
devait tomber d'accord entre la droite
et le front national
il aurait moins de président c'est gagné
pour la majorité plurielle ce qui
rendrait le partage encore plus
difficile
alors après ces différentes informations
jean michel par caron qui revient sur
112 qui est l'information la plus
importante de ce lendemain de vote c'est
la proposition de loi no maigret fait il
ya quelques minutes à cette place même
de soutien sans participation à droite
pour qu'elles conservent un certain
nombre de présidents de conseil régional
là oui on est en train d'assister à un
changement radical de comportement de la
part du front national cet après midi au
cours d'un bureau politique de presque 4
heures bruno mégret ami jean marie le
pen en minorité sur le fait d'abandonner
le préalable de la préférence nationale
pour obtenir des accords régionaux avec
la droite
une position qui n'est pas allée de soi
la discussion a semble t'il était vive
entre les dirigeants d'extrême droite
mais bruno mégret a profité du résultat
moyen de jean marie le pen hier dans les
alpes-maritimes et de son
affaiblissement pour imposer sa ligne
en clair le front national ne compte
plus que deux conditions un candidat de
droite
baisser les impôts et diminuer
l'insécurité ce qui ne paraît pas
insurmontable
conséquence les hommes comme jacques
blanc en languedoc roussillon où charles
baur en picardie tout de l'udf qui avait
déjà précédé d'accord avec le front
national en 1986 pourrait bénéficier des
voix d'extrême droite dès aujourd'hui en
aquitaine le rpr jacques valade a
proposé un contrat d'exécutif au front
national alors que la gauche à la
majorité relative
ce qu'il vient à l'instant de démentir
mais le mal est fait en haute normandie
le rpr antoine ruffenach a décidé de
reporter à lundi c'est à dire après le
deuxième tour des cantonales l'élection
du président de la région au moment où
le front national local estime je cite
invraisemblable que la région passe à
gauche soit au moins quatre régions dans
lesquelles une combinaison droite front
national est envisageable
alors oui on perd on rappelle ce soir
que tout accord de ce genre signifierait
l'exclusion du mouvement les dirigeants
de l'udf ont toujours dit la même chose
mais si quatre présidents de région sont
élus pour six ans grâce au front
national
quel sera le poids de leur exclusion
politique c'est tout le dilemme de
l'opposition par le
en terre devant cette offensive de bruno
mégret qui espère bien à sa façon
devenir un partenaire de la droite comme
n'a jamais voulu ou su le faire jean
marie le pen
merci jean michel si l'on excepte
l'abstention 42% d'abstentions un
chiffre très important à comparer aux 31
% des dernières élections régionales
un autre chiffre est à prendre en compte
celui réalisé par les listes d'extrême
gauche prête plus de 4% des suffrages
des listes souvent constitué au
lendemain des manifestations de chômeurs
2 décembre dernier reportage armes au
but et finira ses jours avant la rentrée
officielle
ils sont déjà là les trois nouveaux
conseillers régionaux lutte ouvrière en
ile-de-france repère les lieux
parmi eux arlette laguiller encore sous
l'émotion investi pas mal
d'établissements prestigieux ne
serait-ce que les pièges déjà de nos
entreprises d'alors je crois que ça doit
être pas plus impressionnant leur entrée
au conseil général pour y siéger
donc on sait je dirais général
aujourd'hui il pose fièrement demain il
compte se lancer dans la bataille celle
des doutes c'est de l'enseignement ou
des transports en commun en ile de
france mais leur fer de lance reste la
lutte contre le chômage
lors de ces élections l'extrême gauche a
triplé son score par rapport aux
scrutins précédents
un vote de protestation
c'était des déçus déjà des premiers
gouvernements se tient de l'ère
mitterrand et qui finalement depuis neuf
mois et bien ne voit pas que les mesures
radicales soient prises pour en finir
complètement avec le chômage or on peut
pas lutter contre la droite et a
fortiori lutter contre l'extrême droite
si des mesures radicales ne sont pas
prises contre le chômage vendredi
arlette laguiller demandera publiquement
à jean paul huchon candidat socialiste à
la présidence du conseil régional de se
prononcer pour l'interdiction des
licenciements collectifs dans les
entreprises en cas de refus elle se
présentera symboliquement la présidence
face à lui le regard sur la nouvelle
carte la nouvelle donne politique mots
croisés spéciales régionales à 22h50
avec notamment un face à face françois
hollande nicolas sarkozy
l'actualité du jour c'est encore
l'évacuation ce matin par la police
d'environ 80 membres d'un collectif de
s'enfuir
les africains qui nous fait si la veille
l'église de notre dame de la gare à
paris le mans le gouvernement n'a pas
l'intention de laisser septembre c'est
une occupation et qui ont commencé avec
celle de la cathédrale d'evry et qui
dure depuis maintenant plus la clinique
pithiviers souvenez-vous avait été
fermée provisoirement par mesure de
sécurité à la suite d'un accident mortel
d'anésthésie c'est être en juillet
dernier cette clinique que posait un
problème plus général de la qualité des
soins dans les plus petits
établissements aujourd'hui la maternité
qui a trouvé les personnels nécessaires
a été rouvert le service de chirurgie
restant pour l'instant fermé reporte à
gilles marinette philippe rey elle
s'appelle miles à nez aux premières
heures du jour bonheur des parents mais
aussi de toute une cité ce matin la
maternité du pithiviers nouveau récit
pas les bébés qui pleurent dans cet
hôpital il n'y a plus de service de
chirurgie et la maternité dispose d'un
bloc opératoire pour les césariennes
d'urgence et de matériel de réanimation
ça c'est l'équipement en or m m lemaitre
de table ranimation évidemment la
plupart des accouchements sont les
complications
24 heures sur 24 une dizaine d'années
stellistes et de gynécologues
qualifiions chirurgie vont se relayer
pithiviers dû pour cela passer une
accord de partenariat les capitales
voisins des temps car on manque
cruellement
les spéciales qui sépara s'il ya pénurie
me font tout cet engouement se vident
professionnels qui sans le condamner les
petites structures ne sera pas compensée
par l'apport de médecins étrangers
bah oui on préfère de loin une récente
du statut d anesthésie ça veut dire une
concertation avec eux une mise à plat du
dispositif de formation qui est en train
de se faire mais vous savez ce sera très
long il ya d'éducation nationale il ya
la santé et les habitudes des syndicats
et cetera pitivi est une expérience de
sa réussite dépend la survie de
plusieurs dizaines d'hôpitaux et de
maternité le vatican a publié
aujourd'hui un texte attendu depuis 1987
le pape jean paul ii avait à l'époque
promis que l'église repentir est de ses
erreurs du passé à l'égard des juifs
le texte publié aujourd'hui n'est pas
visiblement celui qu'attendaient la
communauté juive en effet il est dit
précisément que l'église catholique
n'est en aucun cas impliquée dans le
génocide perpétré pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale contre les juifs marque
maison de ma propre
jusqu'où ira le pas pour une fois ce
n'est pas de sa santé dont parlent les
hommes d'église mais de l'attitude des
catholiques à l'égard de l'holocauste et
particulièrement de leur silence
onze ans après en avoir parlé jean paul
ii l'a fait un texte sur cette question
une année par page pour en arriver là
la shoah est un drame dans lequel des
chrétiens ont été impliqués mehal
individuellement et seulement
individuellement
l'église reconnaît qu'il ya eu un des
manquements qui ont été près de la
vallée catholique durant cette période
et elle dit qu'elle le regrette
jean-paul ii et les auteurs du texte
comme monseigneur du prêt si l'église à
ces coupables ceux qui sont restés
silencieux pendant les persécutions des
nazis et 12 ne fait pas partie de ces
coupables selon vos fils 12 n'a jamais
couvert l'activité de cette évidence les
vidéos évident c'est impensable
comme jean paul ii l'a toujours fait mon
seigneur du pré des fonds pris 12 dans
le texte publié ce matin la communauté
juive elle organise une autre conférence
de presse quelques heures plus tard
madame civile a quelques difficultés à
masquer sa déception des faiblesses mais
plus j'y pense plus à part et ça il ya
sûrement des choses positives aussi on
est décidément loin de l'enthousiasmé
déclenché par le pape
visitant la synagogue de rome en 1986
le président américain bill clinton
rattraper une nouvelle fois par ses
frasques amoureuses supposer cette fois
ci c'est une ancienne collaboratrice du
président qui confie que bill clinton
l'a serré de très près et qu'elle s'est
défendue témoignages nous ton plus
ennuyeux que cet homme de 50 ans
catherine louis lahaye été mariée à un
homme qui finançait le parti démocrate
il s'agissait donc d'amis politiques le
président lui nie tout en bloc
washington philip catherine louis lahaye
n'aura pas convaincu les partisans du
président mais conforté ses détracteurs
il a fallu attendre cinq ans pour
entendre cette confession et après
l'incident la jeune femme a continué à
travailler des années aux côtés de bill
clinton
faute de preuves tangibles c'est
maintenant la parole du président contre
la sienne ont conçu il m'a embrassé sur
la bouche et m'a serrée contre lui je me
souviens seulement que j'ai pensé mon
dieu mais que fait-il
il m'a il m'a touché la populace rim
hama et la miss fait partie lundi le
président resté silencieux trop
peut-être depuis des semaines a parlé
aujourd'hui il persiste à qui je peux
juste vous dire que je suis tout mon
possible pour y voir terme à cette
affaire
j'ai une très bonne mémoire et j'ai dit
toute la vérité vient la rescousse la
responsable de la communication de la
maison blanche qui s'étonne de voir
cette jeune femme qui est venu lui dire
il n'y a pas si longtemps tout le bien
qu'elle pensait du président et ses
conseillers le voir plusieurs fois il
m'a appelé plusieurs fois pour me dire
combien elle voulait nous rejoindre pour
la campagne combien elle voulait
travailler à la réélection du président
le président américain n'est pas au bout
de ses prêtres dans la longue liste des
témoins qui s'allonge au fil du temps on
annonce une petite nouvelle
une stagiaire de la maison blanche qui
s'y trouvaient en même temps que monica
lewinsky
et qui aurait elle aussi beaucoup de
choses à dire en torrent france
ouverture aujourd'hui à rennes du procès
d'un père de famille de 34 ans accusé du
meurtre et du viol d'une petite fille de
11 ans karine après être passé aux aveux
l'accusé est revenu sur ses déclarations
en 1987 il avait déjà été condamné pour
le viol de trois enfants mineurs
florange bukiya qu'elle vit à mener
michel zaretsky prendre quatre ans avant
de comparaître faits de viol la torture
et l'assassinât de la petite karine une
enfance à la zola un père ouvrier
comique est très violent une mère
dépressive 800 hectares dont l'aîné
forces les plus jeunes comme l'accusé à
entretenir des relations sexuelles avec
lui l'habitude des coups l'habitude des
viols selon la défense un terrain idéal
pour que michel bédard est fier des
blocs de graves troubles de la
personnalité n'est pas forcément qu'ils
deviennent en effet ce qu il reste
néanmoins que cet enfant évoluer dans
des conditions de précarité et
difficultés extrêmes avec des parents
alcooliques avec des viols d'ailleurs
entrepreneur a vu un moment été visibles
et ses soeurs également et il va de soi
que dans ce contexte on peut très bien
comprendre les faits pour lesquels il a
été condamné avait failli à versailles
en 1986 michel bazin qui avait déjà été
condamné à 10 ans de prison pour le viol
de trois mineurs libéré à mi-peine 3 en
avril une offre de charisme
tout au long de l'après midi les parents
de karine vont écouter attentivement ces
bonnes et la grille de lecture
le frère de la fillette est là aussi
figée incapable de regarder l'assassin
présumé dans sa petite soeur
demain matin devant la cour et les
parents de karine seront projetées des
images insoutenables tourné par les
gendarmes chargés de l'enquêté
lors de la découverte du corps de la
petite karine suite des plaidoiries des
parties civiles concept de maurice papon
à bordeaux avec aujourd'hui des
accusations très graves m lévy qui ne
voient pas de différence entre l'accusé
et un homme comme klaus barbie chef de
la gestapo de lyon pendant la guerre ce
qui a provoqué la colère de l'ancien
ministre dominique verdeilhan patrick
des choix méticuleux à l'année durant
six mois il a pris des notes posé de
nombreuses questions à papon quand
l'accusé parle de lui il dit
l'interpellateur en trois heures de
plaidoiries l'avocat accumule les
phrases assassines papon technocrates de
la collaboration est un menteur et un
lâche dans le box pape on n'en peut plus
c'est vous le mentor le large serait
temps que thil mais m libye continue le
fichier des juifs et les listes sont les
armes du crime enfin pour l'avocat il
n'y a aucune différence entre barbie et
papon les cris du dit il sont les mêmes
bien sûr barbie intéressant c'est qu'il
a torturé mais si on faisait la
continuité macquart entre le nombre des
déportés à lyon et nos langues des
déportés à bordeaux je pense que d'abord
le palmarès on reviendrait à papon il
part à bordes 8 michel zaoui a lui aussi
la volonté de faire oublier aux jurés la
peine mesurée [ __ ] par nos classes pelle
il n'y a pas dit il de coéfficient dans
le crime contre l'humanite commence à
faire en sorte le saupoudrage ou bien de
la différence dans la sanction possible
et bien pour moi c'est montrer qu'on a
rien
ont pris aux crimes contre l'humanité le
rôle de maurice papon n'est pas
anecdotique mais c'est un rouage
essentiel un maillon de la chaîne du
crime contre l'humanité les avocats des
parties civiles ou ainsi chercher à
anéantir un argument phare de la défense
celui de la victime expiatoire
reconnaissant par là même qu'ils sont au
moins d'accord sur un point avec moi ici
à fond il y a des absents dans le box il
ya 20 ans jour pour jour le 16 mars 1978
au large de la bretagne le pétrolier
amoco cadiz après le torrey canyon
provoqué une marée noire qui resté dans
toutes les mémoires dégâts causés à la
faune et à la flore anr après de longues
années de combat à une indemnisation des
victimes en bretagne cet accident m'a
également une sorte de prise de
conscience des graves problèmes
écologiques posés à notre planète
reportage thibault bayrac la santé
tordu brisé disloqué après mètres sous
la surface de l'eau il ne reste que de
l'homme moquer disent que ces morceaux
de ferraille éparpillés sur le sable
après avoir digéré tout le pétrole
la mère se mange maintenant sur la
carcasse du supertanker c'était un peu
un symbole de voir cette espèce d'étrave
pointé vers le ciel et vert les
habitants de portsall qui pouvait voir
de chez eux
et un matin au bout de quelques années
c'était travail disparu elle a été
coupée
que reste des parts par les traits de
l'amour et de la mer et les parties avec
le courant en fait on sait pas trop
personne n'a jamais retrouvé cette
étrave ces symboles de la marée noire
2 centre eaton de pétrole brut 300 km de
côtes souillées des dizaines de milliers
de volontaires mobilisés pour nettoyer
les plages et tenter de sauver ces
oiseaux mazoutés la nature que beaucoup
croyaient morte pour toujours a pourtant
repris le dessus
on en mangeait les deux chercheurs
étudient régulièrement les côtes
bretonnes et six ans seulement après la
catastrophe
il faisait déjà le même constat plus une
trace de pétrole la pluie le vent la mer
ont tout nettoyé permettant un nouvel
écosystème de s'installer le contrôle
biologique fait que le système a
retrouvé un nouvel équilibre vous dire
s'il est exactement le même cadre un
peut-être pas mais ça c'est pas grave
le système fonctionne la nature se
régénère le tourisme redémarre la
principale victime de l'amoco cadiz et
l'autre force économique local
l'ostréiculture
riom en l'envoi les huttes afin de
crever dans pendant 13 ans ils ont madec
n'a pas pu produire une huître dans les
averses et estuaires où sont installés
les parcs à huîtres
l'eau circule très lentement de
nettoyage a donc été beaucoup plus long
c'est faux c'est lé sol qui n'était pas
pro et à chaque intervention sur les
seuls sauf pour nettoyer ou rcd pas on
remettait en surface des du pétrole les
huit se reproduit aujourd'hui pour les
autres et culteurs comme pour tout le
monde ici nous marée noire n'est plus
qu'un mauvais souvenir
quelques milles de la côte vingt ans
après la mer continue de ronger peu à
peu les derniers l'ombre revient ce soir
à paris de l'homme au masque de fer
d'après le roman d'alexandre dumas la
légende du frère jumeau de louis xiv
caché emprisonné car le royaume ne
pouvait avoir de prétendant au trône un
masque de fer revu et corrigé par le
cinéma américain avec une brochette
d'acteurs prestigieux de leonardo
dicaprio à jeremy aerents en passant par
john malkovich gabriel byrne et gérard
depardieu
ils sont validés ce soir les avant sa
présentation du film nicole cornu
landois merlin plus
pour tous
dans sa tanière
tous réunis à nouveau pour sauver
l'homme au masque de fer qui pourrait
être le frère jumeau de louis xiv
selon l'une des versions de cette
célèbre énigme celle du roman
d'alexandre dumas un double jeu pour
leonardo dicaprio le mois ci après avoir
quitté son masque de fer je dois jouer
deux frères qui sont complètement
différents de travail à faire mais
identiques mais je dois leur donner les
caractéristiques et des très différents
pour en faire deux personnalités à part
entière c'est un défi
était difficile de porter ce maillot
ça rend plus trop fort vous savez vous
l'êtes oui vraiment précis qu on
transpire beaucoup on a très faim
évidemment c'est plus agréable de jouer
le pseudo roi le gentil philippe le
masque de fer est installé sur le trône
par les mousquetaires ou alors le
cynique vrai louis xiv den brink à une
brillante distribution tourner un film
d'action avec le 4e mousquetaire qui
sont quatre immenses recteur un vrai
régal
tu as travaillé avec un seul de ces
acteurs serait un rêve mais travailler
avec les quatre ensemble cela va au delà
de ce que je pouvais imaginer d'année
est la même un déneigement
c'est un rêve parfait nous entraîne dans
un tourbillon d'aventurés on est loin de
l'histoire de
qu'importe c'est une fiction et c'est
une jubilation
les quatre mousquetaires trompe avec
nous ce soir en commençant par gérard
depardieu porthos alors j'ai bonsoir
messieurs
ces quatre mousquetaires ressemble que
même un peu aux sept mercenaires ya un
côté western dans ce film verra oui à
côté mais c'est bien c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui est agréable
en plus ce week-end par dumas revu et
corrigé par rome du ballast avec des
amis et des acteurs de cette trempe
alors donc c'est vrai que moi je vous ai
été très heureux est-ce que vous foncez
vous avez eu quelques surprises avec
l'interprétation de l'histoire de france
par les américains pendant le tournage
qui nous bouffe ou gérard depardieu a
pas du tout mais vous savez je je je je
crois que l'histoire qu'on raconte je ne
sais rien moi d'amour s'allège la
prospection de l'histoire de france
je n'ai pas vécu je pense pas qu'ils
aient beaucoup d'historiens qui ai vécu
cette chose vous admire alexandre dumas
d'avoir fait de l'histoire des histoires
ça c'est vraiment je dis quoi
jérémy un round vous jouez vous le rôle
de d'aramits on a vu dans ce film il ya
cinq stars rajoutons dicaprio lorsqu'on
destin est un ensemble et ce que l'on a
forcément un tournage très très facile
ou est-ce que c'est compliqué j'ai qu il
n'a rien entendu je parle d'un problème
de micro bien je repose ma question
jeremy hunt vous jouez donc le rôle
d'aramis lorsqu'on met cinq stars
ensemble est-ce que un réalisateur a
beaucoup de problèmes de tournage est ce
que le tournage a été facile est ce que
vous êtes bien amusé
oui oui en fait on était entre des amis
des gens que j'admire et j'aime bien
travailler avec ces pauses acteurs les
meilleurs qui soient
c'était un grand plaisir à travailler
avec léo qui est qui a trop de talent vu
sa jeunesse qui trompe aux usa [ __ ]
mais c'était quand même bien de
travailler avec gabriel byrne vous
m'entendez vous êtes vous le d'artagnan
vous savez que les français vont
beaucoup nous en vouloir car nous dans
notre histoire de france d'artagnan est
un très honnête homme est là d'une
certaine façon c'est le traître de la
bande de traîtres
maintenant je sais pas si j'ai pour moi
c'était pas ça du tout pour moi
les assises et non en fait on peut être
en reste c'est quelqu'un qui faisait
d'elle et dallas en bois et à ses amis
il est perçu et rachat en fait
déroulement du soir on voit qu'il n'a
pas l'âme d'un traître
au contraire il est courageux alors john
malkovich vous vous êtes à tous dans le
dans le film nous est le 4e mousquetaire
est-ce que vous connaissiez avant de
tourner ce film est ce que vous
connaissiez son roman d'alexandre dumas
est ce que vous connaissiez les
aventures des quatre mousquetaires
oui je les connaissais je les avais lu
yade très longtemps privée j'étais
beaucoup plus jeune henri gérard
depardieu rend bien à vous est ce que
vous avez eu des problèmes pour tourner
cette machine vous avez tourné en
anglais c'était c'était un problème
quand vous bien ça s'est passé très
facilement
on faisait passer facilement j'aime ça
vous savez qu'au bal demandé si je
comprends ou pas on me dit action j bay
avec jeux du moment que je voyais dans
le regarde mes amis une compréhension
j'étais heureux l'an dernier changera si
on doit parler tout à l'heure j'ai dit
et c'est un peu un western
est ce que vous qualifiez de films
historiques ou film d' aventure une
aventure un film de divertissement
un film qui émeut qui fait rire et puis
qui peut nous raconter qui peut nous
montrer ce que tout bête être
éventuellement le l'histoire d'un roi
d'histoire des mousquetaires c'est un
film où c'est à cet âge holyfield ou
vous allez tourner avec leonardo
dicaprio c'est actuellement la grande
vedette après le succès du britannique
ça a été pour partenaire fait très
agréable ce que vous pensez que c'est un
très grand acteur en devenir ou déjà un
très grand talent c'est déjà un très
grand acteur je pense qu'il avait fait
déjà ses preuves avant dans d'autres
films avant le titanic
et c'est vrai que tous ici reconnaissent
le talent de leurs de dicaprio en plus
il est nos îles et il est jeune c'est un
que c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
professionnel il est très riche aussi
mais je n'ai pas jaloux aucun d'entre
vous ben non la jalousie est pas c'est
pas chez les mousquetaires regardez vos
pages aux abbesses à nous aussi les
alors que je voudrais simplement gérard
puisque vous m'entendez parfaitement que
vous répétez de mises ensemble à la
célèbre formule des mousquetaires alors
un pour tous tous pour un
on regrettera la tous pour un un pour
tous tous pour un messieurs les chances
à vous merci merci d'avoir été notre
ligue bon choix bon maintenant à la
première route de l'or new york san
francisco ont porté par yves parlier sur
l'équipage on a plus de 57 jours battant
al occasion le record de la distance
commis par isabelle autissier 84
reportage alexandre kara
vu du ciel voilà le golden gate de san
francisco u2 le fiancé la porte de l'or
la porte de la victoire pour les mineurs
des mères il faillait son équipage des
chercheurs d'or en ahl de record 57
jours des cubes pour remporter la
première course de l'or cinquante sept
jours pour boucler le tour des amériques
par le cap horn pas relier ces sommes
sont leurs combats tout bleu en tête de
la course de bout en bout devant les
éternels rivaux il avait le toucher
christophe caux bien une histoire
d'hommes qui force le reste de
l'équipage restent motivés pendant une
si longue période et c'est pas évident
sur un bateau près feuilles sont prévues
pour ça et puis il ya le potentiel du
bateau qui a parlé aussi quoi puisque
l'a bien senti qu en vitesse rénovation
avait un petit plus par rapport à ses
concurrents et ça ça nous a bien aidés
dans la tête et dans le journal de bord
du capitaine parliez il est inscrit 57
jours 3h21 le temps d'une victoire mais
aussi le temps d'un record en
franchissant la ligne qui mène de l'île
d'alcatraz au port de san francisco
pariez ses matelots se sont emparé du
record de la route de l'or
la vieille route des clippers a pris un
coup de jeune leurs corps d'isabelle
autissier tomber pour sa première course
en équipage le marin d'arcachon je peux
faire une victoire à 24 perdra
midas des mères une transforme ses
courses en métal précieux
mais à san francisco un qu'on attend
toujours un condor pour vous avez le
fichier écrit stop aux biens voilà juste
avant de quitter le rappel des titres de
ce lundi d'abord les élections
régionales
l'église catholique reconnaît une
certaine façon c'est dans un instant la
vidéo de ce qu'il avance
demain dans les quatre villes